okay so everybody wants to know how you
fuel your training Caroline show me how
it's done
[Music]
you seem to be at approximately 7,000 19
feet 503 our run a little over 21 miles
eight days away I'm leaning for Sweden
[Music]
let me explain a little over a week ago
I traveled up to Lake Tahoe actually
Donner Lake specifically for a two-day
very intense high altitude training camp
with my coach Chris health and Olympics
from her Caroline Buerkle and the
intention was to put in two really hard
really long solid days of training in
preparation for the upcoming
Otilio as we say in the United States
below or I think is how you pronounce it
in Swedish I'm sure I'm butchering it it
is a swim rod ultra that entails
approximately 40 miles of running and
about six miles of swimming over the
course of the day very long race that
will probably take us eight or nine
hours to complete it but what's
interesting is there are 40 transitions
so you're constantly switching it up
between swimming and running swimming
across these little inlets and very cold
water climbing up on a rocks running
across small islands jumping back in the
water rinse and repeat what's super
unique about this race is you do the
entire thing in a customized modified
wetsuit you swim in running shoes you
run with a pull buoy strapped to your
thigh you're allowed to wear hand
paddles as long as you carry them with
you throughout the course of the entire
race so it's very unique and part of the
experience and what I wanted to get out
of this weekend was what it's like to
Train and sort of where all this gear
was about like getting comfortable with
all of these accoutrements so I thought
it would be fun to bring a camera along
take you a little bit behind the scenes
of what this two-day experience was all
about give you a peek into what our
preparation and what our training
looks like so it was really fun it was
really hard and with that said
enjoy my second I feel for for Olympic
success it all starts with a little head
of romaine pick a nice one like so seven
points
hold it step two instead she was gonna
do her the with Hillary miss Kay but
they had to back out because of her key
Elvis she still is a trooper drove all
the way up from LA just to swim in the
lake with us I might hang out a bike in
there it's about 6:30 in the morning day
one of our two-day 48-hour training camp
here up in Lake Tahoe Donner Lake the
water is pretty warm though right
Tomas he's gonna be photographing us
that's the great Chris Mader that's the
great Chris out he's he's in charge
today so we've all been training for
this out till errol race for Boogaloo
for months and months and months but
we've been doing it in the desert of Los
Angeles and now with three weeks out we
figured hey maybe it would be a good
idea to get in some cold water and see
what it's like to swim in these crazy
funky wetsuits know what does it feel
like to swim in our running shoes and
with our hand paddles these are called
hand paddles and get to use them in the
race
[Music]
meanwhile in the back Chuey
oh hey just been finished for a while
[Laughter]
are they working out I'm not
today
so much harder than running 34 miles the
other day way harder but that's how we
did that in 72 hours
now you now you see the load as I like
to say right tomorrow we're gonna run up
there to 8,000 we gonna touch the snow
we got a Texas snow to time chased him
all day and me like and I just got
further and further behind sunflower
greens that's also not very exciting I
have like 700 bars back in the shop all
right so we put in a big day of training
today down at Donner Lake we swam we ran
we did it like 10 times I'm exhausted
we got a little grub that we got a
little rest and now we're gonna do a
podcast another Coach's Corner podcast
with Chris dude I'm exhausted yeah it
was a fun day it was a learning
experience but the good thing is is that
you went through the same struggles that
I did the first time I came up here by
myself
oh so it's comforting emotions yeah we
swam with the paddles with the pole
buoys with the shoes on the whole time
getting out of the water and then
running with all this this gear in what
quickly turned into 80 degree weather
running in wetsuits at altitude Donner
Lake and it was it started out comical
then it became excruciating ly painful
going through the difficulties of a
steady 5 hour day five and a half hour
day like today is important because it
just puts you back into that mindset of
just keep trucking right let just keep
moving forward
don't overanalyze the pace don't
overanalyze the heart rate just keep
moving forward right yeah start doing a
little bit of self-talk and there's
times today we're on top for a reason I
ran ahead of you
because I wanted you to reacquaint
yourself with that j2 back at the lake
in 45 minutes we're gonna go here to the
Pacific Crest Trail a day like today I
would say is why you're fit you're gonna
get this spots where it's so beautiful
that you're gonna say you know what this
is why I like being fit so we got
separated I didn't you say like it's
about 35 minutes of running yep and then
we'll turn around exactly
so I'd gone about 35 minutes and so I
was like I don't know you know so if
he's way over there pass further than I
can see your whole body is a fine-tuned
machine that everything has to work in
sync to do the volume that we're talking
about we're not talking about a two-hour
workout
[Music]
it might be a really good thing for
everybody just to consider what do I
need to get myself motivated human brain
will consistently maybe a event with a
partner or a challenge with a partner
because it does help it's like I got to
do this I love to do it for myself but
there's a little extra you know with
that
hey I'm racing with somebody right and I
want to do well with them for them as a
team
alright I hope you guys enjoyed that
little look behind the scenes in my
preparation for this crazy upcoming swim
run ultra World Championship event for
those that are interested the will be on
September 4th and it will be broadcast
live online if you want to track and
follow the fun go to utter lo swim
rom-com /live I'm trying to create a
team and surround myself with some
talented people so that I can get more
regular with making videos like this
including filming the podcast so I'm
really excited about stepping into that
in the near future in the meantime if
you enjoyed this video if you'd like to
see more of these kinds of things from
me let me know in the comment section
below don't forget to subscribe I
appreciate you guys watching I'm excited
to go to Sweden and I'm definitely
bringing my camera I'm gonna take you
behind the scenes on that so until then
peace plants
[Music]